well the biggest buzz in education
circles these days is coming not from an
educator but a one-time hedge fund
manager in silicon valley the former ivy
league whiz kid has revolutionized math
instruction with a series of online
lessons that have gone viral on youtube
now as elaine corey reports his khan
academy is rocking california classrooms
it all started a few years ago when sal
khan watched his young cousin nadia
struggling with her math homework
he saw firsthand what he says is wrong
with math instruction in america a rigid
model that forces all students to learn
at the same pace obviously the best way
to tutor them is not to tell nadia i'm
going to teach you exponents for 10
minutes even if you only understand
exponents halfway i'm going to move on
to negative exponents in the next 10
minutes khan turned that model on its
head letting nadia set her own pace for
learning he began posting little
10-minute math lessons online and the
rest is history
today with 2100 free tutorials the
nonprofit khan academy has the most
popular education website in the world
and a pilot program begun last fall in
los altos public schools is proof that
self-paced math instruction can also
work in the classroom good morning fifth
grade great to see you this morning i
would remind you that today we're
working on those fifth grade goals in
our classroom on khan academy so let's
get busy these 30 students in cami
thorterson's class are clustered in
small groups around laptops
key to this experiment the kids work
together helping each other to solve
math problems posted on the khan academy
website so
2 is x and 2 is also y
so parenthesis first
2 minus 1 equals
1.
andrew and ryan have already mastered
the fifth grade curriculum so they've
moved on to algebra
after finishing some of khan's online
modules they test their understanding in
a series of exercises so you're at one
minus minus three is negative two
negative two times six
remember remember order of operations
each correct answer earns them energy
points
students compete against each other for
the most points which they can redeem
for cool badges so like moon badges
aren't too hard because i have a lot of
but then here it gets hard about here at
the earth badges while the students are
busy teacher thorterson wanders among
them with an electronic tablet in hand
it displays a customized khan academy
graph showing in real time what each
child is working on dorderson can zoom
in on any student for a color-coded
display of their work the blues are the
problems he got correct the reds are the
problems he missed and i can actually
then go to him and say let's look at
this problem that you missed let's work
through this a little bit after six
months with the khan academy program
thorterson is spending less time grading
tests or preparing lectures and more
time actually teaching one-on-one she
sold on the program it's just brought
our math class to a whole nother level
and you can hear the excitement in the
collaboration that happens in this
classroom they're talking to each other
about math they're they're just
excited some fifth graders have surged
ahead and khan academy has helped slower
kids catch up the pilot program in
seventh grade targeted los altos
students who had fallen several grade
levels behind
nearly all of them have made good
progress
parents also seem to support the khan
academy and the students say they prefer
it to their old math class it's not as
boring as writing in a textbook yeah
there's different modules so you could
do whatever you want
and if we were doing uh math in the
textbook right now we wouldn't be doing
trigonometry
the los altos district is working with
khan to include up to a thousand
students in the program next fall
meanwhile he's been scooping up
accolades awards and millions of dollars
in funding from the gates foundation and
silicon valley backers
khan's been criticized as a dilettante
and dismissed as just another quick fix
for education but he doesn't care the
students the teachers everyone is way
more engaged and there's reason to
believe that many of the students are
learning well ahead of the grade level
and i'm not talking about ten percent
ahead i'm talking about three four grade
levels ahead by september khan hopes to
have pilot programs in a dozen school
districts mostly in california for the
california report i'm elaine cory